[APPLAUSE]
MATAN LUREY: So I didn't get
the after lunch slot this time,
so I appreciate that.
Thank you, Kevin.
Everyone looks pretty awake.
Hi, Mom.
So I'm talking today
about AngularDart.
How many people here
know what AngularDart is?
OK, that's actually pretty good.
That's better than Google.
[LAUGHTER]
How many of you have used
AngularDart at least once?
Also pretty good.
How many of you have used
AngularDart and Flutter
in the last six months?
All right, that's pretty
good, pretty good.
So today I'm going to talk about
AngularDart a little bit-- what
it is, why you work on it, and
what we're working on next.
So let's get started.
All right, a little
bit about myself--
I'm Matan.
I'm a front-end software
engineer at Google.
I actually do interviews for
front-end software engineers
at Google.
So if you do ever
apply, you might get me.
I worked at Google
for about four years
before working on AngularDart.
I actually worked on one of
the first AngularDart projects
ever at Google--
Greentea, the Google
CRM-- internally.
And then from there
I went to go work
on widgets for Greentea written
in AngularDart and Dart.
And then I joined the Dart
team, and I work on AngularDart.
And I think the logical
progression, at this point,
is to probably work on C++ or
something used to write Dart.
You don't want me to do that.
[LAUGHTER]
And if you haven't seen
our repository on GitHub,
this is dart-lang/Angular.
All of our code is here.
All of it's open source.
We push pretty frequently.
Andrew's probably
pushing right now.
We have all of our sub-packages,
the test, the compiler,
the template
parser, the router--
everything here.
It's all managed
in one repository.
We found that model
repo, like Kevin said,
it just works a lot better
for that type of package.
So it's all right there.
And a little bit--
even though most
of you know what
it is-- what is AngularDart, and
why we find this so important.
So here are some
examples of AngularDart.
These are the most
easy examples.
If you can't see what this is,
this is AdSense and AdWords.
Both of these UIs are built
almost entirely in AngularDart.
These are giant applications
built internally
with hundreds of engineers
with the AngularDart team
and the Dart team helping.
These are probably our flagship
applications, so to speak.
But it's not just
AdSense and AdWords,
even though we talk
about them a lot.
For one example, here is AdMob.
Who here's used AdMob?
OK, at least one person.
AdMob's another Ad
product by Google.
One thing I liked a lot
about the AdMob product
is that they launched an
I/O this year with a brand
new redesign written
in AngularDart,
and I think most people
on the AngularDart team
didn't know they were
using AngularDart.
I mean, they adopted it and
migrated everything over,
got it running in production
super fast, super easily.
And that's what we
want everyone to feel
when they're using our product.
So we were super
excited to see someone
get that kind of progress.
So what is AngularDart?
I can tell you what our goal is.
We want you to be able to build
better web apps more easily
and, obviously, in Dart,
otherwise we wouldn't be here.
So what we're trying to do here
is have a productive foundation
for web apps; have an
incremental, fast compiler
and dev cycle;
and, of course, we
want you to be able to write
Dart-- so idiomatic Dart API
and not have to go back and
forth too much with JavaScript
if you don't have to.
So here's an example of
what I mean by productive.
And I'm sure someone
in the back is
going to notice my ligature
font for the equals
and ask me what that is.
So let's ignore that for now.
Basically, we want you to
be able to write pretty much
HTML or HTML-like templates
and have that express
your most complex views.
I personally love the
Flutter style, also,
of writing all of
your code in Dart.
But some developers
do find it easier,
especially when they
wrote HTML traditionally,
to write an
HTML-like syntax when
they're expressing their views.
They can reuse things like
spans and unordered lists,
for example, which don't make
sense in Flutter, obviously,
but would make sense
in a web context.
So we try to give
you a lot of tools
to build views and templates
around your existing HTML,
use existing HTML and CSS
knowledge where possible.
Of course, incremental's
a big part of it.
So one of the things we
actually measure and track a lot
is how quickly you can
change your Dart code,
have it compile the
JavaScript, load
the JavaScript in your
browser, see the changes,
and also be able to debug.
And this is an area
where, in the past,
I think we were not
doing a really great job.
I think we're doing
a lot better now.
But incremental's
a big part of it.
And, in a little bit,
I'm going to show you
how much work we put into
this in the last six months
to a year.
And then the last part's
obviously idiomatic.
It wouldn't be Dart if you
were writing another language.
So when we're using it, like
the test framework for example,
we want it to look and
feel like Dart-- like Dart
you'd write normally on the
server or for Flutter or just
for command-line scripts.
Nothing too crazy or out there.
In this particular
case, like being
able to test that something on
the page says "hello Angular,"
more or less reads
like normal Dart code
with some Angularisms,
of course.
So I'm going to talk a
little about how it works.
Because I think
it's actually really
important in understanding
why AngularDart
versus doing vanilla Dart
or vanilla JavaScript.
So everything can kind of
be summed up by this slide.
I can go through line
by line, if you want,
but that's not too exciting.
Basically, we're
trying to let you
write as little Dart
code as possible
and express your
intent declaratively.
So you have a declarative
template, like I showed before.
And you might have
some metadata.
We use heavy use of
metadata-- in this case,
the annotation at component.
And we want to translate
that into approximately
the equivalent code you'd
have to write if you were
to write your code by hand.
So on the right-hand side is
a real but a little cut-down
example of how we would compile
this template into Dart code.
It doesn't look
that interesting.
But sometimes it's actually
important to have things
in a certain order
for the compiler
to be able to admit better code,
or to be able to make things
more readable.
In this case, we're building
a little "hello name."
And we're going to detect
changes of name changes.
And that's a big
part of AngularDart.
So we want to be able to
express that in very simple code
the compiler can optimize.
And AngularDart's
compiler is really
the big difference in this
and, let's say, Flutter.
Flutter actually runs all of
your Dart code almost as is.
In the VM, we actually
run your Dart code,
and then generate Dart
code from your HTML,
and then run those together
in the JavaScript VM.
So we're generating boilerplate
code for your templates.
We're generating bindings
for change detections,
so we can tell if
things changed.
And we're also
trying to generate
efficient dependency injection.
Dependency injection
is something
that AngularDart and
Angular, for a long time,
has put a lot of focus in.
And one reason that a lot
of Googlers, for example,
really like AngularDart--
because they grew up
with Juice or Dagger or Inject
or probably other things I
haven't used.
So a little bit about what
is new and why this applies.
This is called What's
new with AngularDart, not
AngularDart 101.
So I'm going to go into the
little more exciting parts.
One big issue people told us
is that unlike, say, writing
pure Dart code,
they weren't getting
a really good job of early
detection of template errors.
They would misspell directives.
They would write divs
without closing tags.
And, obviously, the browser
kind of just trucks through.
And sometimes the
compiler did too.
And they really wanted
to know that they
were doing early errors,
and they were seeing
problems in their template.
So we took that feedback.
And we actually did work
on an analyzer plug-in.
So if you're using IntelliJ
or Visual Studio Code today,
with a little bit of hackery you
can actually get your templates
and your HTML analyzed
the same way your Dart
code would be analyzed.
And we'll show you
errors and stuff,
just like you would if you
were writing Dart code.
So here's a blown-up example.
Don't worry-- the plugin does
not make your font that big.
I want you to be
able to read it.
But, in this case, you can
see some red squigglies.
You can see the
problems in the bottom.
This is all brand new.
This is basically us
understanding your intent
with the Angular template code
and identifying problems--
and a lot of subtle ones.
See if you can see
some right here.
"Disabled" is spelled wrong.
You have some wrong types.
You have some invalid syntax.
You have missing quotes.
These things really do add up.
And these things really do
cause production problems.
So we want to highlight
them as fast as possible.
OK.
So this is where I admit--
just like Slav and everybody
else-- some of our patterns,
some things that we were
giving customers to use,
were just not that
Dart idiomatic
and were kind of slow.
Snails aren't really that bad,
but we wanted to identify them.
We wanted them to
know what they were.
And we wanted to see if we
could improve them, if possible.
So here's a really
simple example--
in AngularDart, you can
query for child components.
You can say, oh, I
have three buttons.
And I want to get a
handle to these buttons,
so I can change them.
The way it was implemented,
before I started the team,
it wasn't really
great for performance.
And it was kind of hidden.
Basically, it created a
custom iterable class--
like it actually implemented
the iterable interface itself
with handwritten code.
It discarded all your
type information.
So if you were trying
to use strong mode,
and you expected something
to be a list of Foo,
it was always list of dynamic.
So you couldn't rely on that.
And also you had
this weird thing,
where even thought
it was an iterable,
it had a stream called changes.
And you had to listen to
see if the iterable changed.
That's just not a pattern you
really see in Dart anywhere.
And people were confused.
And it didn't work really well.
So we were trying to
think, how could we
take the same
pattern people want
to use-- find child components--
and make it more Darty?
This is one-- here we go.
So, in this case, this is
almost exactly equivalent.
See if you can even see the
difference in the two code.
On the left-hand side is the
old and the right-hand side
is the new.
In this particular case--
I'm going to highlight it--
all we're doing is we're
changing from this weird
query-list concept--
which actually wasn't a list--
into a plain old Dart list.
And this seems super
subtle and very simple.
But what this does
is a lot of things.
It actually let's
us, first of all,
use the built-in array
type in JavaScript, which
is going to be faster than
some layered, custom iterable
implementation.
It lets us have real
type information,
so strong mode and
other compilers
can actually know I have
a list of child comp
and not a list of anything.
And this is the kind of small
changes, incremental changes,
we want to make to be able to
make the compiler, obviously,
a lot better, but also make
your Dart code feel more
like Flutter code or feel
more like command-line code
and not be very
Angular-specific all the time.
Here's a big one.
I'm sure the right guys
will come talk about this.
And they filed a couple bugs.
And I see some of them smiling.
So that's good.
Here's the part where I
admit that dynamic code isn't
tree-shakeable.
How many people know what
tree-shaking is or have heard
the word tree-shaking before?
OK.
That's used pretty much
at every Dart conference.
It doesn't always
mean the same thing.
Some people call it
dead code elimination.
That might even be the
better word in some cases.
But, basically, it's the act
of trying to figure out code
that you're not going to
use and getting rid of it.
And even though
AngularDart's a lot better
than previous versions, you
can still, pretty easily,
write code that
will never be used,
but we bring it into
your final binary.
So we wanted to see if we can
use the existing code you have
as-is, almost,
and give you a way
to be able to have it
be more tree-shakeable.
So we're experimenting
right now with something
that lets you start
your application
but discards a lot of
metadata that's not actually
used in the runtime
in most applications
and gets you better code
size and performance.
I can give you a
really simple example.
Today, if you write
code like on the left--
you basically
write some classes,
put some annotations on them--
to most people, they don't
think that actually has a cost.
Unfortunately, it actually does.
It generates code like
you see on the right.
Basically, it tries to
create this big hash
map of every single possible
type and factory functions
about how to create them.
And even if you actually
never use this code,
it's not written in such a
way where the compiler can
tell it's never used.
We're trying out the new
bootstrap factory function.
We actually discard
this entire function.
And most applications run
almost entirely as-is.
So when applying
this, for example,
to the GWT Mail Sample app--
one of Kevin's favorite apps--
this is a little sample of the
Google Web Toolkit sample app
that we've converted
to AngularDart.
We took this as-is,
literally no changes,
and just used the new
experimental bootstrap.
And it got 52% smaller.
And that's a real number.
We're hoping to see those
same kind of things.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And the goal here,
again, is incremental.
We don't want people to
rewrite their app every time
we find out there's a
bug in the compiler.
So we're trying to do things
like this that give you
big wins but don't make
you change much or any
of your application.
So yay!
OK.
Here's another big one--
dependency injection.
I talked about it a second ago.
I'll admit now, also-- it's
not really tree-shakeable.
Because the whole concept behind
dependency injection is you
might get things
at run time, and we
have to provide them for you.
But if they're
missing, we'll throw.
But that's not
enough information
for the compiler be able
to remove everything.
So we wanted to be
able to give people
a way also to be able to
generate dependency injection
or service locators
at compile time,
not run time, and get a
little bit better of code.
So we actually
added an annotation
called Injector.generate, which
lets you generate injectors
at compile time
instead of run time.
And I'll show you an example.
"In recent alpha pre-releases"--
I have to put
asterisks everywhere.
If you don't know what
dependency injection is--
it's pretty simple.
It's basically having
your code's dependencies
given to your code instead
of having them hard coded.
So I'll show you
an example here.
Let's say you have
a component tree--
and I stole this
from Ted's slides.
He's going to notice them--
and it provides something
called a Foo service at the top.
And, at the bottom, somewhere,
it injects a Foo service.
We basically, as Angular, have
to provide this hierarchically
across your entire application.
Even if something
does not use Foo,
we have to provide
it because something
might use it eventually.
And here's where we took
it-- again, the same pattern.
The top is the code
you'd write before,
which creates an injector
that provides a credit card
processor and an HTTP service
and some other values.
And you pretty much almost
copy it as-is to the bottom.
And you get this
compiled ahead of time.
It's a little bit
more efficient.
It lets you strip out more code.
And we're hoping to move
more towards this pattern
in the future.
This is my favorite.
Basically-- and this is
something I'll admit--
everyone's going to
smile because it's true--
we found out that incremental
builds were really slow.
They were not cached.
They were entirely
done in memory.
If you wanted to debug
something, good luck.
Also, when people
complained to us,
we were like, what
are you talking about?
Everything works
great-- inside Google.
Because we have a whole
different build system,
and everything
works differently.
So we were not having
the same experience
our users were having.
And we also, at the same time,
were getting a lot of issues,
saying, oh, I want to use a
JSON serializer in Flutter even.
I wanted to use
this build package.
I wanted to use this generator.
So we wanted to have an
all-in-one solution that would
give us the same fidelity
of builds that Google uses
internally but in
Dart and reuseable--
where you would use
code generation today.
So we wrote a new build system.
I know that doesn't sound like
a lot, but it actually is.
It's called
package:build_runner.
I know it's the greatest
name ever created.
We are accepting new names.
If you can tell me a name
you want to use instead,
maybe I can convince Kevin
to rename the package.
So it's called build_runner.
And the reason for build_runner
is very intentional.
First of all,
that's what it does.
And second of all, we actually
have a whole ecosystem
of packages built around
this build concept.
So if you implement
code generators that
implement the build package--
the constraints
there-- it actually
can work out of the box in
many different scenarios.
So we have a basal
implementation of this.
We have a build_runner
implementation.
We actually have an
old implementation
for pub and barback
transformers.
So it can help you
migrate your code.
It can help you use your
code in multiple places.
All right.
So I'm going to
explain this now.
I'm going to try my best.
Who here uses the
DartDevCompiler today?
Not as many as I hoped.
One great thing about
the DartDevCompiler
is it lets you build
JavaScript incrementally
from your Dart sources.
So Dart to JS would get
this huge blob of Dart.
It would have to generate a big
blob of JavaScript-- hopefully,
a smaller blob of JavaScript.
DartDevCompiler has
different constraints.
It actually wants to
build small amounts
of JavaScript per Dart file--
more of a transpile,
more something like you
would see in TypeScript, or you
would see in CoffeeScript, or--
I'm sure-- Elm or Reason or
whatever's cool this week.
[LAUGHTER]
And we tried to emulate that.
And we did a pretty
good job internally
because we have
different build tools.
In this case, when we
compile with DartDevCompiler,
we get to generate one
DDC file for every source
file, every Dart file.
And you can see the arrows
start pointing more and more
on the left because,
actually, to build DDC C,
you have to know what the--
you don't need to know
what source A is, source B,
and source C. This could
spiral out of control,
as you have a really
big application.
And, even here, compiles
took longer and longer.
And even when they
were fast, as soon
as you restarted your
computer or restarted Travis,
everything would have to
start over all over again,
even in a huge graph.
OK.
It gets more complicated.
We also wrote a compiler
for AngularDart.
So not only do you have to
depend on the Dart files,
you have to depend on
something on the Angular
outputs of those Dart files.
And, again, now you see
even more and more arrows.
We went from this to this.
And, again, imagine
this like 50 times wider
and 50 times deeper.
This is explaining the Wrike
situation or anything else,
like why builds
are taking so long.
This really can
get out of control.
And the builds had no way
to do anything about it.
We couldn't even
cache because there
was no guarantee
everything would
be built in the same order.
So, normally, what I
did, at least locally,
is I would run pub serve and
then wait, say, 30 seconds.
And the one thing I liked
about that a lot is I
got to go make a cup of coffee.
And, really, you could sit
there with the espresso machine
and probably do the whole
thing and come back,
and sometimes it wasn't done.
Or my favorite-- you could go
on r/programming on Reddit,
and then you could
spend a long time there.
And then, hopefully,
by the time you're
done with all 11
articles, the build's
completed without an error.
And that's not what we wanted.
Obviously, our second goal was
incremental fast compilation.
So that doesn't
make a lot of sense.
So I'm going to show you
today a not-live stream--
because I'm too
scared to do that--
but an emulated live-stream
terminal of what it looks like.
This is really copied and
pasted from my laptop yesterday
with everything.
It had no special flags I'm
hiding or anything-- just
on a live demo.
So this is the first
build, all right?
So I cloned my Angular
repository to disk.
And I'm going to go into it.
And instead of running
pub serve or pub build,
I'm going to run something
called "build_runner build."
Again, names are in progress.
But I'm going to do a
build of my application.
Then I'll wait a tiny bit.
And this is going to come up.
And it's going to say that
it generated a build script.
What is that?
It's going to say it
generated an acid-graph.
What is that?
That took some milliseconds.
Then I wait a little bit more.
It says "build running."
That's good.
And then, finally,
after we're done--
it took about 33 seconds,
almost 34 seconds,
with 2,258 outputs--
again, whatever that means.
So not too bad--
it took 30 seconds.
I'm still making cups of
coffee or browsing Reddit.
That's not too impressive.
That's not what I wanted.
So why do I care about
build_runner then?
Why was that exciting?
Really, there's
three parts here--
one, it's automatically
configured.
So just like
Transformers you don't
have to do much as an end user.
If you use a package that
requires code generation,
it just works out of the
box-- with a little bit
of configuration on
their part, not yours.
You can build.
You can serve.
And one of the brand new
things you can do is you
can actually just watch.
If you don't want
to serve, you just
want to output to a
directory somewhere,
you can totally do that.
And it works with AngularDart
today and the alpha pre-release
that we have available.
So what does this do?
It's almost the exact
same graph as before
but with this nice little
green box, which I like a lot.
And, again, this is me
simplifying a little bit.
But, basically, for every
library, or every source file,
we can actually cache
the result on disk,
and know that that
cannot possibly change,
and let that whole
part of the graph,
or lots of parts of the
graphs, stay cached,
persistent on disk.
Imagine you have a
package or 10 packages
and you're only modifying one.
The other nine packages
stay cached on disk
forever until you update
Dart or update AngularDart
or do something really big
that requires an invalidation.
So now I'm going to
show you build_runner
after the first build, which is
the actually impressive part.
So this is what
you see afterwards.
Unlike pub serve
or pubs build, you
do have an on-disk build folder.
You can actually see the
generated files on disk.
If you want to click
into them and see
what happened, why
something failed,
why something is big or not,
you do have the real Dart
files on disk.
You have the real DDC
JavaScript files on disk.
You can really inspect
everything right in your IDE.
And then let's do
this one more time.
That's not the
animation I wanted.
All right, as you
can see here, it
does run the same build graph.
It takes some time.
But this time it took 2.4
seconds instead of 30 seconds.
That's a pretty big deal.
That's from 30
seconds to 2 seconds.
[APPLAUSE]
So that's the fidelity
we're looking for.
And I know that's not perfect.
But that two seconds
is the difference
between going to
get a cup of coffee
and just refreshing your browser
tab and blinking a few times.
So we're going for that
blinking a few times motif.
And the really exciting
part, which I find exciting--
maybe others don't--
is, if you have no changes,
it takes under a second.
So this might not
sound like a lot.
But let's say imagine
that you have a Travis
instance or a CircleCI
instance running
your continuous
integration, and you
change some change
log or some comment
somewhere that does not have
any impact on your application,
your Travis will be able
to build in under a second.
So this is actually a huge deal.
This encourages you to make
frequent updates to your repo,
not these big, giant updates.
And this is also the difference
between going for a walk
before your CI's done and just
working on your next task,
branching and working more.
So pretty good.
One more thing.
You can cache in on Travis.
So this is an
example for Travis.
Just like your pub
cache folder, you
can cache your Dart tool folder.
That has all these generated
files and the acid-graph
and all this information we need
to not reproduce information
to make your builds fast.
And I'm pretty sure it
works for other stuff too.
OK.
But what about serve or watch?
I don't want to just build
things over and over again.
OK, that's fair.
It's the same thing.
So instead of doing
build_runner build,
you can do build_runner
watch or build_runner serve.
Watch will actually
add file watchers.
And the nice thing about this
is it starts up a Dart VM
and keeps it hot in memory.
So as the VM and the JIT
gets warm, it stays open.
And this is the same build
that took 2.4 seconds before.
Now it's taking
200 milliseconds.
So this is the kind of
build that we actually
do expect for small changes.
You keep this thing running.
You make changes.
You refresh your browser.
And it should all happen
in under a second.
OK.
So what is next?
I have a few minutes still.
If you're looking for the 2018
roadmap, we don't have one yet.
It's a work in progress.
But I'm going to tell you--
I'll talk a little
about what we want
to do when identifying
the 2018 roadmap.
So the number one thing that's
important to us right now
is releasing a 5.0 beta whenever
the SDK 2.0 beta gets released.
And that might sound
like me hand-waving,
but the reality here
is that it might
be small tweaks of
the type system,
small tweaks to core libraries.
And we don't want to
give you a stable product
and then say a
week later we need
to have a 6.0 breaking release.
So we're going to stay in
this kind of alpha level
until the SDK gets
almost completed.
And then we're going to release
a beta and go from there.
There's only three
things we're targeting.
One is we're targeting smaller
code for faster startup.
We want less JavaScript to be
admitted just for the simplest
apps and complex apps.
We're adding a new
template parser, almost
from scratch, that gives
you a lot better errors.
It's actually the same one
used by the analyzer plugin
that I showed you
earlier with the IDE.
And we want to give
you more features
to do little performance
tunes yourself.
So one big request
from people is
that, OK, we can write
really complex apps,
but when we hit
performance problems
we don't know what to do.
We want to give some
common solutions
to some common problems,
like the injector issue,
so you can tweak your app.
And once we do all
that, we'll actually
find the mythical 5.0 final
release and be on our way.
OK.
So thanks.
That's everything.
If you want to see the code I
referenced today or anything,
you can go on
github.com/matanlurey,
twitter.com/matanlurey,
or you can email me
at matanl@google.com.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]